ننتقل الى تامر في نيكولايف تامر يبدو انك
تقف في منطقه استهدفت هناك فطار هذا القصف
الروسي المكثف للمنطقه قربنا اكثر من
المشهد لديك
بالفعل سهام القصف لا يهدا هنا على مقاطعه
وعديده المقاطعات الجنوبيه ابدا من حيث
انتهى الزميل حسان فيما يخص التصريحات
اللافته والمهمه للمتحدثه باسم قياده
عمليات الجنوب الاوكرانيه العقيد نتالياه
التي قالت بشكل واضح بان هنالك انزعاجا
روسيا على الارجح من الدفاعات الجويه
الاوكرانيه التي باتت تصل الى اوكرانيا
والتي تسهم في الحد من
استهدافات على المناطق المدنيه والمناطق
العسكريه الاوكرانيه وقالت بشكل واضح بان
التكثيف في هذه الهجمات سواء على العاصمه
كييف او المقاطعات الجنوبيه على وجه
التحديد هو ياتي في سياق محاوله استنزاف
القدرات الجويه والدفاعات الجويه للقوات
الاوكرانيه وفي الحقيقه الهجوم كان واسعا
اليوم على مقاطعه اوديسا مقاطعه خيرسون
بالاضافه الى عدد اخر من المقاطعات هيئه
الاركان الاوكرانيه عن خمسه عشره استهدافا
صاروخيا جديدا اطلق من البحر الاسود
باتجاه اوديسا وخيرسون على وجه التحديد
وقال قبل قليل المتحدث باسم القياده
العسكريه في اوديسا بان الدفاعات
الاوكرانيه تمكنت من اسقاط ثمانيه من
الصواريخ في البحر الاسود اطلقت اصلا من
سفن متواجده في البحر الاسود وقال بان
الخطر لازال قائما لا زال متواصلا دعا
السكان الى ضروره الالتزام بالتحذيرات
والتنبيهات الجويه في المقاطعه الجنوبيه
وقال بالفعل بان هنالك
حاملات صواريخ محمله بصواريخ مجنحه من نوع
كليبر مستعده للاطلاق ومتهيئه للاطلاق في
اي لحظه على اوديسا وعلى المقاطعات
الجنوبيه تحدث عن استهداف واقر باستهداف
منشاه وصفها بالمنشاه الصناعيه واشار الى
مقتل مدني واصابه اخرين ايضا عداد الضحايا
في مقاطعات جنوبيه اخرى الحديث عن خيرسون
وفقا للسلطات العسكريه الاوكرانيه هنالك
قتل اربعه من المدنيين واصيب عدد اخر من
الجرحى حاكم خرسون الاوكراني تحدث عن هجوم
صاروخي على قلب المدينه وعلى العديد من
القرى والبلدات الواقعه على خط التماس بين
القوات الاوكرانيه والروسيه وتحدث في
المقابل عن تكثيف القصف المدفعي بالمدفعيه
الثقيله للقوات الروسيه واشار الى اكثر من
90 هجوما خلال الساعات الماضيه واطلاق ما
يزيد عن 500 قذيفه على العديد من المواقع
المدنيه الماهوله بالسكان واشار الى تضرر
بنيه تحتيه لا سيما خطوط ماء وكهرباء
وايضا تجدر الاشاره الى ان القصف الروسي
وفقا للادارات العسكريه الجنوبيه تكثف
ايضا على زبروجيا الحديث ايضا عن نحو 90
هجوما بالمدفعيه الثقيله براجمات الصواريخ
بالاضافه الى طائرات من دون طيار على عديد
القرى الواقعه على خط التماس بين القوات
الاوكرانيه والروسيه في زبروجيا زبروجيا
التي ايضا تتعرض فيها المواقع الروسيه
لقصف مكثف كما تقول السلطات الاوكرانيه من
قبل الجيش الاوكراني المتواجد هناك لا
سيما في ميليتوبل وتوك ماكنا شكرا لك تمر
الصمادي مراسل الجزيره كنت معنا من نيك